along with big budget disaster flicks
and edgy rom-coms thrillers with a
strong female lead were a huge part of
the cinema landscape in the 1990s
whether it was sandra bullock tracking
down conspiracies in the net or julia
roberts escaping an abusive spouse and
sleeping with the enemy
audiences were eager to see women taking
on nefarious men
few films personified this trend as well
as the ashley judd and tommy lee jones
starring revenge tale double jeopardy
beware there are spoilers ahead in the
film judd plays the quiet and kind libby
persons whose wealthy husband nick
vanishes while they're alone on a boat
although libby is clueless as to what's
happening she's eventually convicted of
nick's murder and sent to prison
but plot twist nick is very much alive
and he purposely framed libby for his
death
after one of her fellow inmates clues
her into the legal concept of double
jeopardy
the idea that someone can't be tried
twice for the same crime libby vows to
use this loophole to make sure nick
doesn't get the chance to enjoy the new
life he's created for himself
the plan shall falsely admit to
murdering nick in order to be released
from
prison on good behavior then kill nick
for real as she's already been tried and
convicted for that particular crime
while the core idea of double jeopardy
is well not exactly legally airtight who
really cares
the movie is an enjoyable slice of late
90s thriller fun which is probably why
it's currently on the list of top 10
movies on netflix
it kind of makes you feel warm and
tingly all over don
but back when it came out the movie took
a beating from critics
the late roger ebert was more charitable
than many in his two and a half star
review
though he still called the film not a
successful thriller but with some nice
dramatic scenes along with the dumb
mystery and contrived conclusion
entertainment weekly described the movie
as toothless and a strained reworking of
the fugitive real views wrote
unfortunately this movie is too focused
on action melodrama and plot twist to
allow for more than a moment's
intelligence to worm its way into the
script
despite the middling reviews the movie
was a hit with audiences
it spent several weeks at number one at
the us box office and it raked in nearly
178 million dollars across the globe
considering its current popularity on
netflix it's clear that something about
double jeopardy has always connected
with the general public despite the
silly plot
reviews credited ashley judd for her
performance though real views critiqued
the movie as a whole they did lavish
praise on judd's performance saying
ashley judd almost makes libby credible
in fact the actress is so good that
against all odds we like the character
even though she only uses about one
percent of her brain cells
double jeopardy has gone on to become
one of judd's most noteworthy roles but
her part in the film originally went to
another actress
according to an interview in urban
cinephile with the film's director jody
foster was originally attached
he explained she fell out of the project
because she got pregnant and we had to
recast that's how ashley judd wound up
in it
second choice or not the movie helped
cement judd's status as a go-to star for
thrillers with tough women at their
center
before double jeopardy she starred and
kissed the girls along with morgan
freeman
a film based on a popular james
patterson novel which sees freeman's
detective alex cross on the hunt for a
serial killer named casanova
judd plays a would-be victim of casanova
who manages to escape
and then partners with cross to help him
track down the killer after double
jeopardy judd teamed up with freeman
again for high crimes where she plays a
lawyer who finds out her husband has
been hiding his participation in war
crimes
and following that she starred in
twisted as a san francisco police
officer with a drinking problem who
finds herself at the center of a
conspiracy when her former lovers keep
turning up murder
unfortunately twisted is also notorious
for having a one percent rating on
rotten tomatoes
but clearly even over two decades since
the release of double jeopardy audiences
are still connecting with their
portrayal of a woman hell-bent on
revenge
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you